what was uh
what was prison like whether it's
germany or whether it's australia
what were the some of the darker moments
in prison the united states prisons are
awful
awful evil places now it just really
there's nothing nice about them
there's the guards in l.a
which they never went out everyone i
went to it seemed like the further east
i went to oklahoma and it was nicer
but all of them on the west coast there
was hatred there
and they got really stupid people hired
just incredibly
hatred by the guards and and the inmates
like
i speak spanish and i walked in to the
spanish
tv room and it was saying no you can't
come in here
and i walk across to the black hey get
out of here
white boy it was just like what man i
like all you people you know
and so i walked down to the white people
and said show us your paperwork
you can't come in here until you show
your paperwork we don't let snitches and
homosexuals and all this sort of stuff
in here so
they have so it's just like man i don't
want to be in here
i mean it sounds absurd but you're
saying like the basic humanity is gone
completely completely in the guards it
was just like
come here reeves and i walk up to him
and get the [ __ ] out of my face
he sticks his chin out like for me to
break his jaw yeah
like what in the world man
i love people and it's just yeah you you
got this joy
to you yeah you have a joyful nature how
and it didn't seem like that broke you
not a bit
how did you persevere did you know i
didn't even think i persevered but i
i try to enjoy my life wherever i am
every day i do
i uh i ran every day and like i told you
why do you run so roger i said
to help me suffer these fools and uh i
played a game of chess
every day almost of my life in there and
i read two books a week
and i talked with people storytellers
guys would come in tell us another story
roger
give us a point tell us one you never
told us before and so it was just nice a
lot of them have original boys
they just picked their country music and
it was all right
red morgan freeman's character in the
shawshank redemption
says the following these walls are funny
first you hate them then you get used to
them enough time passes you get
so you depend on them that's
institutionalized
is there truth to that a hundred percent
i couldn't even see the walls
except whenever i was planning on
escaping in shawshank redemption
he spent so many years in prison that
he almost didn't know what to do with
himself with himself once he left
once once he was a free man that's the
you get so used to the the system
the the rituals having to follow orders
even being treated poorly all those
kinds of things that you become
dependent on
well uh down in australia i spent the
first
a little over a year in in the shoe it
was like um
did you see the movie the um silence of
the lambs thank you
and he's there i had five five or six
guards looking at me with a one-way
mirror
yeah and that's whenever i thought i
might never get out i got a life
sentence
i had all this time waiting here in
germany
and so that's they had a uh
they had a computer in there but it
didn't have a program on it and i wrote
so i just started writing these little
stories of stuff i did in my life
and i wrote one line and i wrote a
million words
with them looking at me so it's after a
year they let me out it wasn't long
before they put me in a place called
self-care and particularly i was in what
they call the lifers pod
there was 268 men in self-care there and
uh
it was it was unbelievably good that we
were left alone
basically they was there or the guards
were certainly there but
they had their their shack and we had
apartments
for four apartments to the building
and uh six men to the unit with your own
door and a key to it
and a kitchen dining room freezer
refrigerator
and they gave you allowed just 360 a
week to buy groceries
and i cooked for about 16 years and
learned to cook good and the people and
other people
may have their specialties and uh
so that was that was quite uh it wasn't
so like being in prison it was somewhat
living with me and it was difficult man
i had some good good fights and carry on
but
you don't get along with everybody but
uh
then whenever i came back to the united
states i was laughing and talking
and when i got off the plane in uh l.a i
had three
three marshals with me from australia i
was slammed upside the wall i mean hard
put ankle backs on and
handcuffed so tight till he cut my vein
off face forward face forward lands
apart
good gracious and walk me up 50 steps
and turned me over to the marshals and
they took part of that off
that was a border patrol that was there
over my marijuana charge from 1977.
yeah from america i did 11 years for
parole violation
now they want me for more violation and
they put me in down in los angeles they
put me in
the marshes put me in in there and they
put me in isolation
i thought what in the world they got me
for isolation for
doing anything how long did you spend in
isolation
more than six months so i uh
after three or four days as the little
judas window slide open
and a man a nice looking man in a suit
come there hello reeves i want us
just want to see what you look like i
saw you a national geographic
documentary
and it does me pleasure to keep you in
isolation and he slammed the thing and i
couldn't get out of there
and by law the u.s parole commission is
supposed to give you a hearing within 90
days
so murray paid a lawyer 7 500 and he
never picked up the phone
somebody got to him
who's that somebody you think
christopher cannon was his name and i
don't know who got to him
but some he didn't he didn't do anything
to get me out of there yeah i got one
15-minute phone call a month
and i couldn't get out so then after six
months they
shipped me to put me on conair
double shackled and black box on my
hands and i went to went to
oklahoma and they let me out on the the
uh
on the floor i couldn't imagine then i
could call after a couple of days
and they said there was a man here from
washington give you a
parole here and you only got you at 3
30. so he left he said he'd be back next
year
what i've been in now over six months so
then there was a lovely little lady she
was the uh
case manager or something she said you
can ask for parole on the record
and i said please do i said i'll send
them an email and the next day i got my
parole
90 days later they sent me to terminal
island put me in
the place there with the infillet i
guess since i'm as old as i am
78 years old so they put me in the
people in there dying and
wheelchairs and legs off and arms off
and cancer so i was in there and i
pushed the fellas around
and i went come out the chow hole there
and i went to go to the right to get me
a haircut and
two mexican guys there lieutenant
another one walked between us and he
went like the boot
i could outrun you and they slammed me
put me on the ground
handcuffed me and put me in the shoe for
a week
i got out man they put me in it back in
the place they treated me rough
so i got in a little more trouble and
they put me back in the
in the shoe and i wouldn't come out they
had that uh
the virus was out killing people so they
killed eight people in that unit i was
in
oh wow so i mean i wouldn't even come
out to take a shower i had
i had a little straw that i put in the
in the sink and i
i'd take a sock that i had and scrub
myself with it with some smoke
and glass water over my head and then
cleaned the floor up and put it in the
toilet
so that was your time during the
coronavirus pentameter i got out last
april
right in the middle every night and they
were dying bad in there
so i was treated worse for that last
year in america than i was for the whole
20 years in australia
18 years in australia and then you were
a free man at the end of that year they
put me out and sent me home and
the parole officers couldn't even come
they weren't working they were just
doing everything by video
he said better not have a drink the only
constitution thing was i couldn't even
have a drink of wine
so uh after a year they uh i had i had
to take psychiatric treatment
every week i had to go talk to the
psychiatrist psychologist
and me and her got along great she was a
good christian woman we just chatted and
talked
and i think they said so i had to pee in
the bottle every week i said i've been
in 33 years how many
pissed you think i've had never been
dirty the only thing if you all want to
clean when you come get me
you